all right let's play a little word
association with the characters involved
in
this almost shakespearean drama that's
playing out between rogers and the
packers let's start with the star let's
start with hamlet aaron rodgers first
word that comes to mind
i love you you called him hamlet that's
funny i call him the puppet master he's
trying to pull the strings you know he's
got the marionettes in his hand he wants
to make the front office dance he wants
to make the coaches maybe dance a little
bit too even though he says that his
problems aren't with them but that's the
way he's trying to play this and like
he's trying to exert every single bit of
leverage that he has as one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time as the
reigning mvp in order to get exactly
what he wants so that's what i think he
is right now he's a puppet master
i'm going to call him determined because
even though we don't know exactly what
he wants and i don't believe it when
james jones says that i've talked to
aaron and this is fixable i think that's
part of the manipulation that aaron
rodgers is engaging in he knows which
guys that he talks to are going to be
talking to the media he wants to create
the impression it's fixable because then
the next question is hey packers why
haven't you fixed it aaron rodgers
former teammates are saying it's fixable
go fix it
i think he's determined to get whatever
it is that he wants and he's also
determined not to tell anyone what he
wants and we'll find out what he wants
and and look maybe he's got great
political instincts because politicians
good politicians never tell you what
they want and they act like what they
ultimately got is exactly what they
wanted so maybe that's what he'll do
whatever he gets he'll take the position
that's what he wanted all along
yeah exactly so if that's if that's the
case then you know that's exactly why it
almost feels like he's he can return to
the packers because then he can say yeah
look this is what i wanted guys and now
we're going to be okay and now we're
going to go play and now we're going to
go win and like i don't want to put i
don't want to talk about this anymore
that's all in the past i'm not here to
talk about the past you might go full
mark mcguire
all right mark murphy first word that
comes to mind
uh mr contradiction
because this column that he's talking he
wrote you know that he does on the
packers website where he's saying you
know this thing has divided our fan base
and you know the less we publicly say
about it the better and what do you
think what are you doing that's exactly
what you're doing you're talking about
it publicly so why are you doing that i
don't really get that that doesn't seem
to make any sense to me like one thing
especially that question that he was
asked about it it didn't really seem to
have to do with anything that had to do
with aaron rodgers so why are you
bringing aaron rodgers into this
especially if it keeps dividing the fan
base i bet it's going to divide that
shareholders meeting too
well and look i was going to say puppet
master for murphy i i'll say uh what was
the word i was thinking of and now it
just slipped out of my brain all
together mad scientist that's what it is
because i think that he is fully aware
of what he's doing
there is a certain element of
experimentation to what he does look
miles i i believed a couple of years ago
based on the report that tyler dunn had
as to the dysfunction between mike
mccarthy and aaron rodgers that mark
murphy liked the fact he said i think in
that very article if this pisses some
people off this may be good for us i i
think that he signed off on the jordan
love thing knowing that it would it
would spur aaron rodgers to have a big
year and i think he he wants to mix the
chemicals just right
so it doesn't explode in his face and
when he says it's dividing the fan base
that's aimed at dividing the fan base
and getting aaron rodgers to feel
pressured to show up because he doesn't
want the fans to not like him he thinks
he knows murphy does how rogers is wired
and what he's afraid of and what he's
afraid of is the fans hating him so i
think he's the mad scientist who's who's
shaking up all the various liquids and
hoping that it it ends up being
something that that leads to good things
not bad things for him
yeah probably i mean it makes sense that
he's doing all of this but you know we
just had that thing up there with the
question and it's just like bro why
they're talking about washington
generals and like well hey why are you
putting that in your column
the question they selected to answer
begins with don't let the bastards bring
you down
and he brings up aaron rodgers in
response which you can only tell me he
must regard aaron rodgers as a bastard
that's the only that's the only logical
interpretation of that all right brian
good coons first word that comes to mind
uh krause or goat but with a lower case
you know because it's just like this is
now the whipping boy you know if you've
got aaron rodgers reportedly calling
brian goodacouse kraus jerry krause in
these text messages it's like well you
know he's constructing
these rosters that are going to the nfc
championship game but maybe it's
happening in spite of poor good coons as
opposed to because of him so if that's
the way this thing is really going to
work and like if that's the person that
aaron rodgers has the most issue with
for whatever reason then yeah i mean
that's probably how he's going to be
remembered in this situation
i'm going to say not really in charge
because i truly believe that i saw
someone say recently that the general
manager of the packers is the most
powerful person in the nfl who isn't an
owner it may used to be that way not
anymore because a couple of years ago
when they reconfigured the front office
when it was mark murphy and mike
mccarthy and ted thompson they kind of
split it apart and i think when brian
gudekunst was hired they split it apart
and murphy took some of the powers that
gudekuns would have and it was murphy
who was supervising mike mccarthy that's
what it was goodikus became the gm
before mccarthy was fired murphy's got
more power
good koontz isn't really in charge the
way that the gm would have been in
charge in past years and and and this is
a the mad scientist is the man behind
the curtain all this angst directed at
goody kunst hagen's mur i think it's mur
and i'm not being critical i'm just
trying to interpret and analyze i think
murphy's the guy who's calling the shots
here all right matt lafleur
first word that comes to mind
uh this isn't about me you know because
lafleur doesn't seem to be the person
that rogers has a problem with at least
publicly right you know when he went on
kenny's main show he was talking about i
don't have a problem with jordan love i
like my coaches and all of that so i
mean unless rogers is still miffed about
that field goal thing that happened is
he kind of alluded to on one of those
jeopardy episodes that he hosted like it
doesn't the problems don't seem to be
between aaron rodgers and matt lafleur
again they've gone 26 and six in the
regular season the last couple of years
i don't think anybody really expected
that out of matt wilford i certainly
didn't when he got hired they've been to
two straight nfc championship games you
know i think we can say that there are
still some things that they have to do
better but it's not like aaron rodgers
didn't win an mvp this year with matt
lafleur calling plays so it doesn't seem
to be about him
i'm gonna say restrained
because look other coaches
who
had gotten their careers off to the
start that leflore has with a 26-6
record and two straight conference
championship appearances
we have seen they make a power play
they they try to take over a little bit
and and i really do think and i said
this not that long ago that matt lafleur
was hired by the packers in part because
mark murphy and bride gudekunst read him
as a guy who wouldn't do that he was a
guy who will have success
and not try to take over not try to
upset the internal power structure so
he's very restrained he has every reason
to be upset he seems to be patient about
it he's not doing anything about it he's
not you know going in and shouting at
guys and sticking fingers in chess about
what the hell's going on what are you
doing to my football team and i think
that's exactly what they were looking
for when they hired a head coach after
mike mccarthy all right jordan love
first word that comes to mind
i didn't ask for any of this i know
that's not one word but like look he
didn't i mean the poor guy he like they
trade up to get him and then he just
sits there as the third string
quarterback all season long and now he's
just the subject of mystery and really
if aaron rodgers
weren't you know doing what he's doing
in this offseason then some of the
conversation would be like okay is
jordan love progressing is jordan love
gonna be able to be a backup quarterback
this year what's his future hold but now
it's all oh man are you ready to take
over for aaron rodgers and that you know
that quote we played um in the beginning
here where he said obviously aaron and i
have a good relationship is that obvious
hey i don't think that that's very
obvious i mean rogers has come out and
said you know i have no problem with
jordan love and all that but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
obvious that you have a good
relationship with him i think it's good
that he does but manny
i if i'm jordan love like this is just
such a weird thing because i'm trying to
replace one of the greatest quarterbacks
of all time and i did not know that that
was gonna happen before i got drafted
and now here i am and this is what this
weird situation is
i i i am to pay homage here to
darren gant who was with us for years
and this is one of his
regular when he's not when he's not
making gags about uranus on the planet
he
this is jordan
yes
jordan love comma poor bastard comma
that's one of gant's go-to because uh
that's how i feel i it's you know
he didn't ask for it as you said he got
drafted he didn't get to choose who
would have chosen this what quarterback
in his right mind would have chosen this
mess that this has become exhibit a for
my argument against the draft and i
think i may even get sims a little
wobbly on his stance that the draft
should remain
jordan love should be playing for any
team but the packers right now this is a
horrible situation for him to be in all
right devonta adams first word that
comes to mind
uh you better fix this or i'm out like
you you need to fix whatever the
situation is with aaron rodgers because
otherwise that guy's probably going
elsewhere and even if you franchise him
you're gonna probably have a disgruntled
devante adams because you've taken a
quarterback that he knows is one of the
best of all time that he has
tremendous chemistry with and there's
and he's upset so you can't have that
and also you know expect that devante
adams is going to be happy now he said
that he's not going to hold out and of
course he's not going to hold out
because you get fined and you can't wipe
those fines away because he's entering
the last year of his contract but that
guy and aaron rodgers have some serious
chemistry and if you don't figure that
thing out that's gonna be a real big
mess
i'm gonna say pr genius
because i i think that
his comments from the other day he said
exactly what he needed to say there's
not going to be any nasty text message
or cold shoulder from aaron rodgers
jordan love has no basis to be upset
with him he said exactly what he had to
say doesn't know enough about jordan
love yet and he supports his guy aaron
rodgers and jordan love's not going to
be upset aaron rodgers isn't going to be
upset and whoever the quarterback is is
still going to be inclined to throw
passes
his way in what is a contract year
whether the packers pay him come next
year or someone else all right packers
2021 super bowl chances first thing that
comes to mind
um
[Music]
there's a you're telling me there's
still a chance
because there is a chance
i mean if rogers comes back
you know then it's gonna be all right
but
if he's not there
then they're probably pretty pretty bad
but i don't know man i just
there's of course there's still a chance
but not if jordan love is playing i mean
i just i can't see that part nah i don't
know
i i'll tenuous that is literally the
first word that came to mind i mean they
missed it the last two years they had
great teams
are they going to be better this year
with
the aaron rodgers distraction
i don't care what is said and done
between now and week one this is not
going away
unless unless they fire brian gudekunst
or sign aaron rodgers to a lifetime
contract
where where they basically surrender all
power to him and trade jordan love along
the way
unless they conclusively and completely
reset
somehow to
pre-2020 draft
and it's clear that jordan love is out
of the picture and aaron rodgers has won
and he'll be there as long as he wants
to be there that's the only way the
distraction is going to be removed so
when they were 13 and 3 and unable to
make it to the super bowl without
the the distraction that they're going
to have this year it's it's only going
to be worse for them in 2021 they're
going to have a hard time making it to
the super bowl but a fully determined
aaron rodgers man who knows maybe i'm
still rooting for the final scene of the
longest yard both versions win the super
bowl
pic go get the game ball
stick it into mark murphy's stomach and
say put this in your trophy case and
walk away for good i i hope that's the
final outcome because that will mean it
was a compelling and fascinating nfl
season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports